i
[Música]
cómo
en bolivia se ha desatado una fuerte
polémica porque el presidente luís ar se
ha pedido a la población aguantar y
resistir los embates del coronavirus
hasta que lleguen las vacunas destinadas
a inmunizar a toda la población vacuna
bleu de bolivia lo que podría ocurrir de
forma masiva a partir de abril el
gobierno ha suscrito dos grandes
contratos para adquirir vacunas uno de
ellos para tener la vacuna rusa sputnik
5 y la otra para adquirir la vacuna
astrazéneca sin embargo ninguna de ellas
está todavía en bolivia y se tiene
previsto que los próximos días lleguen
las primeras 3000 unidades de la vacuna
rusa lo que ha generado críticas de
personal médico y otro tipo de personal
sanitario que dicen que eso no alcanzará
ni siquiera para empezar a inmunizar al
personal de primera línea frente a las
críticas el presidente ar se ha acusado
al gobierno transitorio de jeanine áñez
de no haber hecho las gestiones
adecuadas para la adquisición de la
vacuna más allá de estas polémicas
políticas lo cierto es que bolivia
enfrenta a una virulenta segunda ola de
kobe 19 sin tener todavía las
para inmunizar a su población
[Música]
el continente africano ha resultado ser
una vez más el gran perjudicado en este
caso en la carrera por la obtención de
las vacunas anti kobe para frenar la
pandemia que también azota este
continente mientras en el norte global
se debaten los tiempos y las logísticas
para llevar a cabo las campañas de
vacunación en áfrica en general todavía
no se tiene acceso a las vacunas y es
que los acuerdos entre los países ricos
y las empresas fabricantes exacerbar aún
más las desigualdades esto es una
amenaza para áfrica porque muchos países
no pueden hacer frente a la barrera
financiera concretamente marruecos y
egipto dos de los países más afectados
del continente son los únicos que han
recibido dosis suficientes como para
poder empezar una primera campaña de
vacunación dosis de la china sino pharma
y sudáfrica que es el país más afectado
del continente se prevé que se puedan
desarrollar algunas vacunas en su
territorio al igual que en nigeria y en
kenia pero aún no pudieron empezar
ninguna campaña y según la onu se
calcula que alrededor del 20% de los
africanos podrían estar vacunados a
finales de año esto es una cifra muy
preocupante y muy a baja porque aunque
áfrica sólo representa el 3 por ciento
de los contagios a nivel mundial
los números no dejan de crecer y ya son
más de 35.000 los casos diarios
[Música]
muchos países de asia no van a empezar a
vacunar contra la cob y 19 hasta febrero
o marzo principalmente porque el virus
en esta región no está tan descontrolado
como en europa o eeuu es el caso de
corea del sur cuya buena gestión de la
pandemia le ha permitido negociar con
más calma los precios de las vacunas que
ha comprado de fabricantes como fisher
como modernas aguas atrás séneca le ha
permitido también realizar un análisis
más exhaustivo de los posibles efectos
secundarios de estas vacunas lo que
ayuda a enviar un mensaje de mayor
tranquilidad a la población
el plan surcoreano pasa por recibir las
primeras vacunas en febrero y
administrar las primeras dosis hasta
marzo a los trabajadores sanitarios de
alto riesgo y aquellos que trabajan en
centros de mayores en el segundo
trimestre se vacunarían a aquellos
mayores de 65 años y el resto de
trabajadores sanitarios y en el tercero
a aquellas personas con enfermedades
crónicas y en personas entre 64 y 19
años de este modo el país asiático
pretende alcanzar la llamada inmunidad
de rebaño es decir tener vacunado entre
el 80 y el 90 por ciento de la población
para el mes de noviembre
[Música]